In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 23rd, on which we commemorate, the Holy
New Martyr, John of Appyrus.
Saint John was born at Konitza in ancient Appyrus of Muslim parents.
His father was a well-known Sheikh and a member of the Dervish Order.
When John was 26, he settled in Joanna, where he was respected by everyone as the son
of a Sheikh and a Dervish himself.
He became the Dervish, accredited to Yusuf the Arab, the Master of Ayatollia, who commanded
the Turkish forces at the time of the war against the Russians over possession of the Ionian
lands.
Although he was still in the darkness of unbelief, the young man lived according to his
conscience and so behaved in many respects like the Christians.
He stayed in Ayatollia after the departure of Yusuf, drawing ever closer to the Christians,
and in the end, asked for holy baptism.
No one there dared christen him for fear of the Turks, and so it was on the island of
Ithaca that John was baptized.
He settled in a village called Kietomeron, married and remained in obscurity, working as a
simple field watchman.
In the year 1813, John's father got to know that he had become a Christian.
He sent two Dervishes to look for him so as to bring him back, if possible, to their belief.
Him they found, but none of their sophistries was able to persuade the saint to heed what
they had to say.
Following the visit, the authorities of the region were informed who he was, and sent
soldiers to seize him.
To each of the judges' questions, the saint simply responded, I am a Christian, and I am called
John.
After greatly ill-treating and humiliating him, they decided to behead him.
At the time of the execution, they would not permit his hands to be loosed to make the
sign of the cross, so the saint cried out like the thief.
Remember me, O Lord, when thou comest into thy kingdom.
He then submissively stretched out his neck, and so offered his life to God on the 23rd
of September, in the year 1814.
The Turks wanted to leave his body for the dogs, but it was taken up and buried secretly
by the faithful.
It was later transferred to the monastery of Brousseau's, and hidden in a crypt, where it
was later discovered in the year 1974, through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus
Christ, our God, have mercy on us and save us.